[Musique]
oui c'est ce qui arrive quand tu décides
de boire un café à tourner une vidéo
alors comme ça on n'a pas dormi pendant
des jours après avoir vu la vidéo
hahaha quelles faiblesses les amis je
suis récemment tombé sur un nouveau ce
raid horrifique et cette fois ce qui est
flippant ainsi que ça pourrait tellement
nous arriver à tous c'est horrible ce
que vous êtes prêt à ne pas dormir moi
oui alors on y va aujourd'hui on va
parler de ce qui est arrivé à ryan alias
lost for love sur twitter en août
dernier décidément c'est là où toutes
les histoires drôles commence
apparemment le mois d'août sur une
sautée match et vous graille anne s'est
vu demander par son voisin de garder son
chien pour la modique somme de 40
dollars par jour ce qui est carrément
cool
vraiment ils décident de partager la
nouvelle à sa communauté en disant
[ __ ] ma voisine m'a demandé de garder
son chien la semaine prochaine elle m'a
dit qu'elle me donnerais 40 dollar par
jour et je dois le garder cinq jours
trois jours plus tard ryan nous dit
qu'il a rendu visite à sa voisine et qu'
il a des trucs à nous dire premièrement
quand il est arrivé dans la maison de sa
voisine
il faisait complètement noir alors qu il
était 19 heures et en plein mois d'août
il fait pas du tout à 19h et quand il
dit qu'il faisait complètement noir
c'est qui faisait complètement noir on
voyait que dalle dans l'appareil
apparemment cette dame elle a 40 ans et
elle vit seule dans une maison immense
rien nous indique qu'il a pas de
problème avec ça qu'ils jugent pas mais
c'est toujours effrayant de voir
quelqu'un qui vit seule dans un endroit
dix fois trop grand pour lui non pas
qu'on est jaloux ou quoi mais on se dit
[ __ ] il vit seul là-dedans ça il faut
pas le cafard ou alors ça se trouve il
était pas seul et sa famille est morte
il nous dit ensuite qu'il était un peu
en flip parce qu'elle parlait d'une
manière bizarre et dès qu'elle parle
elle avait besoin de toucher des parties
de son corps à ryan très bizarre très
tactile la dame devrait nous cachent pas
qu'ils passent un très mauvais moment
quand il la rencontre mais il se dit
bats les couilles c'est que pour cinq
jours et je veux faire de l'argent allez
on y va la dame finit donc enfin par
l'année dans une pièce sombre dans
laquelle se trouve le chien dans une
petite cage
la dame lui dit alors de le garder dans
la cage quand ils sont occupés de le
laisser sortir uniquement quand il a
besoin de faire pipi et il se dit mais
qu'est ce que c'est que ce bordel un
chien il n'est pas fait pour être en
cash d'une pièce sont humides tu le
laisses gambader dans ton jardin tu fais
pas un chien c'est un être humain comme
nous il a besoin d'eux qui fait sa vie
un peu ouais je passe un message oui
alors il continue de parler la dame lui
dit qu'elle a déjà dû faire appel à des
gens pour s'occuper de son chien mais
que certains d'entre eux l'ont
empoisonné elle a donc dû s'occuper de
leur cas des gens qui ont empoisonné son
chien qu'est ce que tu veux dire par là
à ce moment-là ryan se dit qu'il va
laisser le boulot à quelqu'un d'autre
que c'est beaucoup trop glauque beaucoup
trop bizarre l'ambiance dans cette
maison comment elle est cette dame
et puis au final il pense à l'argent il
dit franchement y'en a que pour cinq
jours je m'occupais d'un chien calme
probablement comme une merde une fois le
boulot terminé je la reverrai plus
jamais de ma vie bat les couilles à
légiférer and roll chez lui on est le 15
août et il commence à garder le chien le
16 août donc le lendemain et il nous
fait une petite blague ne dit pas nous
inquiéter qui réussira à trouver où elle
cache les cadavres des gens qu'elle a
tué bonne blague ryan bonne blague
attend donc de passer la nuit dans cette
maison nous sommes le 16 août
ryan va chez sa voisine une marche est
une petite vidéo de lui qui marche dans
la maison et effectivement cette [ __ ]
de maison elle fout le cafard mais quel
cauchemar [ __ ] on croirait la maison
dans resident evil cette série se trouve
au mieux d'une famille glauque au pire
c'est cette maison là en fait qu'à dans
le jeu on va passer mythos aussi la
manière dont ses fils mais il avec son
téléphone en mode flash c'est aaron tout
glauque bref il fait un petit tour dans
les chambres voir si à personne il prend
des petites photos pour nous montrer
mais mais une vidéo d'un truc qui
retient qu'un jeu son attention puisque
c'est extrêmement glauque
make pourquoi il ya une poupée assise
sur une chaise qui regardent le lit
c'est pas loin la même chaise d'ailleurs
que celle où david ça soit la nuit quand
tout est glauque regarde le matelas gros
y'a pas de draps dessus ces deux matelas
ont pilé même l'horloge de table où ils
sont posés par terre sur la moquette
sinon plus accrochée au mur mec s'est
trouvé ça à ce moment là tout le monde
ya rien de se barrer les mêmes une meuf
qui dit tu peux vivre même sens les 200
dollars mais tu ne peux pas vivre si tu
n'es plus envie cours la raison ryan
continue de faire un petit tour de la
maison c'est normal il va y dormir
pendant quatre jours il a plutôt intérêt
à être au courant de ce qu'il ya dedans
il nous dit que toutes les pièces de la
maison sont ouvertes sauf une seule dont
il n'a pas la clé selon lui cette pièce
mais nos sous sols sous sol dans lequel
se trouve peut-être les gens que cette
dame a tué je sais par rennes remarque
aussi quelque chose d'autre c'est que
depuis qu'il est arrivé dans la maison
il ya un vieux poste radio qui fait du
bruit qui grésille comme si vous avez l
avait mis entre deux stations donc a pas
de musique ça fait juste du bruit c'est
juste flippant gratuitement ryan prend
une autre photo d'une des bibliothèques
de la maison dans laquelle se trouve
beaucoup de livres de républicains
extrémistes blancs
rennes se dit que c'est bien le genre de
personne qui serait capable de commettre
un frère ryan nous avons ensuite une
vidéo dans laquelle il pense avoir
entendu un bruit venant de derrière une
porte
à vous d'en juger clairement là il faut
partir en coin il faut arrêter de faire
comme dans les films d'horreur là quand
le perso principal il entend du bruit on
sait clairement que c'est un esprit qui
veut lui couper la tête mais il y va
quand même on sait jamais mais part en
courant quelqu'un lui répond en disant
n'ouvre pas la porte donc tu n'es pas
absolument certain que c'est une
personne réelle derrière et pas un
esprit et votre mec lui dit mais il
traverse les murs les esprits plus tard
je trouve ça drôle désolé ça me fait du
bien ça me fait décompresser la de cette
histoire de merde encore d'horreur
l'arrêt nous dit ensuite que l'un de ses
followers a remarqué un truc bizarre
avec la poupée sur la vidéo qu'il a mise
alors il décide de retourner pour
checker de ses propres yeux
ryan post alors une vidéo en disant
qu'il était en chemin pour la pièce où
il ya la [ __ ] de poupées de ces morts
et il a entendu un bruit venir du
plafond plus précisément venir de la
ventilation
mais arrête gros et le chien dans
l'histoire inventée là pour s'occuper du
chien mec t'es même pas avec lui non
monsieur bah rien nous dit qu'il a une
nouvelle fois entendu un bruit venir de
la porte d'entrée de la maison et décide
de prendre une vidéo à travers l'oeil de
la porte pour nous prouver qu'il ya bien
personne devant la [ __ ] de maison je
deviens parano avec ses vidéos
le chien a envie d'aller dehors pour
faire ses besoins mais là nous dit qu'il
a trop peur d'ouvrir n'importe quelle
porte de la maison y compris la porte
d'entrée
donc ça va attendre on peut clairement
le comprendre qu'on ferait l amf dans sa
situation mais franchement le cher je
mets dans l'évier ou au dessus des
toilettes tu as des merveilles tu vas
apprendre à faire pipi comme un humain
pendant cinq jours voilà après je me
casse c'est bon non vraiment c'est chaud
ryan fait alors une autre découverte il
se trouve que soul un délit dans une
pièce il y a des [ __ ] de cloud open
monter un meuble ikea elle a fait tomber
quelques outils à la pas fait gaffe ryan
pourquoi tu ne pars pas en courant
m'explique nous as tu n'as pas de jambes
avant il fallait le dire 18 minutes
après qu'ils paraissent une éternité
pour les gens qui suivaient le thread en
direct rien donne des nouvelles idées
qu'il est toujours vivant et que quelque
chose est arrivé il dit qu'il a entendu
quelque chose tomber par terre dans la
pièce où se trouve la poupée il nous
rappelle qu'il n'a touché à rien dans
cette pièce qui n'a bougé aucun objet il
décide alors plutôt que de rentrer chez
sa mère en chaleur en appelant la police
de retourner dans la pièce où il ya la
poupée pour voir ce qui s'est passé
vidéo
vous l'avez vu ou pas regardez bien par
rapport à la vidéo qu'on a vu tout à
l'heure un truc à changer la tête de la
poupée à bouger cette [ __ ] de poupées
à bouger c'est horrible un défaut lower
de rennes à une bonne idée en lui
demandant de regarder dans les étagères
où il ya des bouquins s'il ya un bouquin
sur le paranormal peut-être que ça pour
indiquer que la propriétaire de la
maison elle fait des trucs un peu
bizarres des rites où on sait pas trop
quoi et ça pourrait expliquer ces
phénomènes paranormaux ou pas que pour
l'instant ryan n'arrive pas à expliquer
lui-même
et devinez quoi ils en trouvent et nous
envoie une petite photo de ce bouquin
rennes se rend compte qu'il est
seulement minuit alors qu'il a
l'impression que ça fait six heures
qu'il est dans cette [ __ ] de maison il
dit alors qu'il veut pas être comme la
fille qui m'a en tout les films
d'horreur mais il demande aux gens s'il
doit rester ou pas pendant l'heure la
plus flippante qui est de minuit à 1h du
mat ysmal ans à revoir des tas de
messages de gens qui lui disent mais
crantée cliques et ses claques le chien
ait fui et certains de ces messages le
font vraiment flippé notamment un mec
qui lui indique siconet pas mal
en tout ce qui est sûr céleri et
paranormal et que mettre des clous son
espace devient team peut vouloir dire
plusieurs choses soi que la personne
essaye de repousser quelque chose de
sérieux et d'agressif ou alors qu'il ya
des zones maudite dans la maison ryan
décide alors de se parer de la maison ne
sais pas si la pression ou pas on ne
sait pas si tout ça est vrai mais [ __ ]
ce que c'est flippant
les amis n'hésitez pas à aimer cette
vidéo si vous voulez dormir chez un
escroc je trouve ce trade génial parce
que ça peut tellement nous arriver des
jobs d'été où tu dois garder un enfant
tu dois garder un chien bref tu dois
aller dans un autre endroit une autre
maison et tu découvres les lieux et tu
découvres avec les lieux des trucs qui
sont un peu bizarres qui font qu'ils
étaient pas très serein quand même et
puis tout part en vrille et en plus à
cela s'ajoute la paranoïa et c'est
terrible quoi dans ces situations tu
deviens parano de fumay clap eu aucune
objectivité pour toi tout veut du mal et
tout est vilain geste ça vous aura plu
c'est un peu différent des deux sets
qu'on avait déjà fait mais j'aime bien
varier un petit peu les plaisirs si je
puis dire dans celui-là ce que j'aime
bien c'est qu'on n'a pas la fin le mec
est pas allé jusqu'au bout n'est pas
resté et c'est cool il a pas été le
personnage héroïque d'un film d'horreur
qui est con et qui meurt ça fait plaisir
on peut être que content pour ryan selon
vous qu'est ce qu'il y avait dans cette
[ __ ] de maison mais moi je trouve
juste que l'histoire de la poupée c'est
trop flippant ryan il a jamais dit si
tout ça était fake ou pas mais en tout
cas ça a l'air tellement
vrai ça a l'air encore plus vrai que les
deux autres ce raid je trouve c'est
horrible du coup c'est un peu moins
flippant mais comme ça à l'air grave
vrai basse et plus flippant en fait au
final voilà je suis en pls comme à
chaque fin de vidéo comme ça au moins il
est 18 heures il fait bien jours c'est
bon jus bien on est loin de l'orage et
de l'avenue de la dernière fois je vous
fais des bisous et qu'est ce que je vous
souhaite la bonne nuit allez ciao
[Musique]
m
monsieur
[Musique]